My guest this week is the American,
anti-gun violence
activist, Fred Guttenberg.
Fred's 14 year old daughter, Jaime,
was killed at her high
school alongside 16 others
by a teenage gunman.
I want to talk to him
about how so many have become
desensitized to gun violence
and whether he thinks his great friend,
President Joe Biden, can
really tackle the issue.
Fred thank you so much for being with me
and talking to all of us today.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for having me on.
I had to start by making sure,
we heard just something
about your daughter, Jaime,
first of all, because
this is why we're here
and I wanted to ask if you could be
as kind to tell us a little
bit about what she was like.
My daughter was what every
parent would hope for
in a child.
She was kind, she was
beautiful, she was decent,
she was tough, she was well-behaved.
My daughter was a competitive dancer.
That's how she spent
her time out of school
constantly practicing to dance.
But what she also was is
somebody who understood
that not all kids had the same abilities.
And so she dedicated her personal time,
when she wasn't in school,
when she wasn't dancing
to volunteering for
different groups of kids
with differing abilities,
to make sure they had
all the same types of opportunities
for social connections
and for development.
When she was in school,
she despised bullies,
and would put herself in the
middle of somebody bullying
and somebody being
bullied to make it stop.
To the point, where as her dad,
I sometimes got real nervous about it,
but that's who she was, you know?
And I wasn't gonna stop her
from being that amazing person.
She had her life figured out.
She knew what she wanted going forward.
She wanted to be a pediatric
physical therapist.
She dreamt of working in a place called
The Paley Institute
where they do surgeries
on kids with limb deformities
to help a child walk for the first time.
She wanted to be married
by the time she was 25.
She had life figured out.
She was amazing.
She sounds like she had a lot figured out
and a lot of ambitions and hopes.
And I suppose something
you have spoken about,
and I know would be be a situation
any parent would find themselves in
if they were in your situation,
which sadly many parents are in America,
part of your work is looking at that.
Yeah.
Is you will have rerun that day many times
in your mind.
If you don't mind me asking this as well,
I did wanna ask what you
remember about that morning.
She went off to school.
Well let's start
with the fact that it was Valentine's Day.
February 14th.
And it was a perfectly normal morning.
And I say normal with
all the good and the bad.
You know, the kids were
getting ready for school
and they were running late
and being siblings they
were blaming one another.
My son was the driver.
He was gonna drive them both.
And because they were running late,
I was rushing them out the door
and I kept on telling them,
'you've gotta go, you gotta go.
You're gonna be late,
you gotta get to school'.
And those were the last words
to my two children that morning.
My last words to my son and my daughter
that morning were not, 'I love you'.
It was, 'you've gotta go,
you're gonna be late'.
I was sending them to school.
I never expected that later
that day I would find out
I would never get the chance again
to tell my daughter how much I love her.
But I didn't do it that morning.
And it is something I will live with
for the rest of my life.
It is the reason why I tell every parent
and everybody who loves somebody else
to make sure you never missed a chance
to look someone in the eye and
tell them eyeball to eyeball
how much you love them.
'Cause you never know when you
won't get that chance again.
It's such an important message.
Thank you for sharing that Fred.
I really appreciate it and-
Thank you.
You are then in your day,
it's February 14th and going
about your business as usual.
Yeah.
And how do you learn
something is wrong?
Is there a phone call?
How does this knowledge
start to reach you?
Just after 2pm, I get a
phone call from my son
and, you know, kids in school
today have cell phones,
so there's regular communication
throughout the day.
And my son calls me just after 2
and he was a bit of a jokester.
So he calls and he says,
'dad there's a shooting at my school'.
My initial instinct was 'what
the heck is he talking about?'
You know, that's a weird
thing to make a joke about
but what is he talking about?
But he immediately, you then
said 'and I can't find Jaime'.
Now my son looked after
his sister like a hawk.
He would never play games with her safety.
And then the second he said that
I knew this wasn't a
joke and he was serious.
And so I said to him, 'where are you?'
And he said, 'they're making us all run,
but I can't find Jaime'.
And I said, 'you need to run'.
He goes, 'but I can't find Jamie'.
He kept saying it to me over and over
and telling me he wants
to turn around and go
to where they know the
shooting was happening
in which that building.
And I'm like, 'you can't do that.
You need to run.
I'll worry about your sister'.
And as I'm on the phone with
him and he's crying to me
that he can't find his sister,
there's gunshots.
As I'm on the phone with him,
it's the shots on the third floor
it's the shots that
were killing his sister.
He listened to them and I listened to them
on the phone while I was
speaking to him,
convincing him to run.
Because of those shots,
I was able to finally convince him
to keep just running as far
from that noise as he could.
And he made it to safety.
Unfortunately, the rest of that afternoon
was all about my wife and I
trying to find our daughter,
hoping she was okay,
hoping the fact that we
couldn't reach her was only
because maybe she dropped her phone
and eventually she'd call us
from somebody else's phone.
It was getting to the hospital,
so that we could
try to find her there
hoping she was now injured
and couldn't reach us.
And it wasn't until,
you know,
around 5:30-ish
when we learned
through a friend of mine
who was a police officer
that she was shot and killed.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
I really am. And
apart from all
the things
that will come
with such devastation, your
life really changed that day
in completely other way
because of how we're speaking now,
which is part of your message.
Yeah.
You, you suddenly found yourself
in a position where you
knew about the violence,
the gun violence, the
mass shootings in America
but you obviously until that point
hadn't known about them
in quite the same way.
And you find yourself with a cause.
Listen, I live with this
intense guilt
that my voice wasn't a part of
this before it was my family.
I'll never get over that.
But it's a part of this cause now.
The crazy thing is it
didn't happen immediately.
The first 24 hours are,
were actually a blur,
while I knew my daughter was killed
I hadn't really started to focus
on the notion that this was gun violence
until the next day at night
when I went to the Parkland vigil.
And at that vigil the
mayor asked if I wanted
to take her speaking slot
and I hadn't prepared anything
but I said, you know, what the heck?
And I went up there and I
looked at this crowd of people
thousands of people crying
with candles and lights.
And that was the moment where it hit me
that this was a gun violence
that broke my family,
that broke my community.
And I just remember telling people
that vigil about my daughter
but saying to everyone in the crowd,
'this time gun violence
came to the wrong family
to the wrong dad and to
the wrong community'.
And
I went home that night
and I walked in my house
and I said to my family and friends
who were there who didn't go to the vigil,
I'm gonna break that effing gun lobby.
And it's been my mission ever since,
is to break that lobby
and to break their grip
on our legislators and
getting effective legislation
to do something about
gun violence in America.
And
I can't stop.
Well, there are many people
who are very grateful
to you because they would also say
that they would be scared
to do it, you know,
because of the carrying of guns
and because of the threats,
because of the risk.
Sure.
Are you ever scared
to speak up and and say anything
'cause of what's happened
to your family as well?
Yeah.
Well, because of what
happened to my family
I've lost this capacity for fear.
What my daughter had,
running down the hallway
with an active shooter
carrying an AR-15 at her back.
You know, people need to
remember, my daughter knew
it wasn't like she was caught by surprise.
She knew what she was running from.
She was in the hallway,
she was the second to last to be shot.
She made it to within
one second of safety.
What she had was fear.
Genuine, real fear that
I'll never ever fully
be able to understand or comprehend.
And because I'll never have
the level of fear that she had,
you can't intimidate me anymore.
You can't. Words won't do it.
What I really have found more than that
is the majority of people in this country
have been supportive, have
been amazing, and give me hope
because the majority of people
in this country are like me.
It's not that they're anti-gun,
it's they're anti-gun violence.
They want to do something about that.
And so for every person who
tries to intimidate or threaten,
I can genuinely say 'I don't care'.
But to everybody who understands
what my mission is
and is supportive, I can
genuinely say 'thank you'.
And I hear you because I do.
And yet what you said
and I'm very struck by
it, I'm moved by it.
Where you said at the beginning
of our conversation that you have guilt
about not adding your voice before.
It doesn't mean you didn't care.
It's about something else
which I wanted to get your view on
which is
how do you get people to care
to the point where they
also push for change?
Or rather, how do you stop
people from being desensitized
to this because it's so common,
gun violence in America.
Yeah.
How do you do that?
You know, it's such a great question
and I look back and
I'll just use Sandy Hook
as an example.
I felt horrible emotion
over it, anger over it.
I watched all the news reporting
over it and I did nothing.
I did nothing.
And I lived in this bubble.
I mean this was Parkland, Florida.
This was the community,
actually a lot like Newtown
where you never see this happening.
And
I allowed myself to stay in this bubble,
part of what I do now to help people care.
People always say to me,
'I can't imagine how you feel'.
I go out of my way every chance I get
to help people imagine how I feel,
to help people imagine the terror,
to help people imagine the violence,
and to help people imagine
themselves in that.
And not me, because I think
at the end of the day,
the more people realize
while this happened to somebody else,
but it could happen to
me when I go to the mall,
it could happen to me when
I go to the shopping center
or the movies.
It could happen to my family
when I send them to school,
the more likely they are to
become part of solving it.
And I will tell you, if you
look at the last three elections
in this country, doing
something about gun violence
has been a top voting issue.
It has changed election outcomes.
And I think people are listening now.
And if you look at polls,
over 80% of America wants to solve this.
We are winning the fight,
but moving the political system
in this country is a lot of work.
Well, I mean you say that as well,
but I'm also aware that
we've seen recently in states
where there have been mass shootings
politicians reelected who
are anti-gun reform as well.
I mean there is that reality,
they may have been voted
for for other policies.
Politics is not a one
policy thing of course.
But you've spoken very
publicly about your bond
with the president, with Joe Biden.
Yeah.
I know that he was
an important figure for you
and a relationship you
say you wouldn't have
without what happened
to you and your family.
But do you have faith that
he can be the president
to make that change?
Because, you know, there
isn't that much longer left
in some ways and we dunno
what's gonna happen next.
Without question, not
only do I have faith,
I can actually point to the fact
that something has
already been accomplished
that is historic and hasn't
happened in over 30 years,
which was back in April he
signed the Safer Communities Act,
a real piece of gun violence
prevention legislation
that does really big things
to start to finally bend the curve
and reduce gun violence.
Is it everything I could have hoped for?
Is it everything I would've wanted?
Well, no, it's not.
But, it was a real significant package
that was able to get bipartisan support.
And I'm actually, to this day,
so thankful for his leadership on that,
for the leadership of
people like my friend
Senator Chris Murphy, who
negotiated in the Senate
nonstop to get it done.
Even when, and he will tell you this,
I didn't have faith that
he could get it done.
I never saw him being able to accomplish
in the Senate what he
did, but he got it done.
But Fred, there's been
more violence since,
there's been more shootings.
Sure.
How do we move or how do you
and the people you are working
with move to stop that?
What needs to change?
Well, listen, and it's a great question.
If, you know, we passed
this back in April.
If you look back to when my
daughter was killed in 2018,
there were about 300
million weapons in America.
By the time we passed this legislation
there were 400 million
weapons and ghost guns.
So the reality is we haven't,
you know,
the legislation passed is
gonna be forward looking
and I believe will have
a real dramatic impact.
Right.
But we have to come to grips
with the reality of the numbers
of weapons that we have.
I will tell you for me personally,
the Holy Grail of solving
gun violence in America
at this point, because
of the numbers of guns
that are out there, is through ammunition.
And I am working to pass something
in the United States
Congress called Jamie's Law
which seeks to extend
background checks to ammunition.
There's no requirement for a
background check on ammunition.
So, you have all these weapons out there,
many of which are in the hands of people
who are what's called
a prohibited purchaser.
So they have to get their gun illegally,
or they steal it or they trade for it,
and they walk right into the
store and buy the bullets.
If we can get background checks
on ammunition, we stop that.
We'll save lives immediately.
And so for me, that's
the Holy Grail right now
of solving this problem.
And I'm not gonna stop.
That's fascinating.
It makes a lot of sense because
of what's already in play,
like you talk about and, you know,
we will see what happens
because it's so political
and it's such a strong lobby.
Yeah.
This is a very simplistic way
of asking something quite complex.
But, because you've
looked at this so much,
who do you blame for
your daughter's killing?
Hmm.
A lot of people.
Let's start with all of
those who failed to stop it
when they had different chances to do so.
Let's start with the person
who made the decision to do it,
but also
I can not focus on the political reality
that we live in a country
where that killer,
in spite of all the red flags,
was able to buy the gun.
And so I do blame the
legislators who failed
to do anything meaningful
for all of the years.
I look at, just my
daughter was born in 2003.
The year she was born
there was actually a ban
on assault weapons in
America that expired in 2004.
And you can look at
the trajectory of sales
after that ban expired.
You then fast forward to 2007
and the Heller Supreme Court decision,
which put in place this whole
phrasing around common use.
And the industry built common
use into a business model.
And they kept on manufacturing
and flooding our streets
with more and more and more
of these weapons every year
to the point where they were
no longer just being used
from a hunting or sport perspective.
They were now being used overwhelmingly
in daily violent incidents.
So I blame everybody who's a part of
building that system,
whether it's the Supreme Court decision,
whether it's all the legislators
who failed to do anything to prevent
this explosion of weapons on our streets.
I blame them all.
And those legislators who still exist,
who refuse to acknowledge the significance
of this problem and who
fight back and who use BS,
you know lies, to continue
to push that system.
They have blood on their hands right now.
I blame them right now.
And so, stopping the next
one requires defeating
still more people and we're
gonna continue working to do it.
You mentioned right at
the top of that list,
unsurprisingly, rightly, the killer
who hasn't been given the death sentence.
Instead, it's life in jail.
What was your reaction to
that quite recent decision?
For the past almost five years now,
my life has really been very much
wrapped around what's gonna happen to him
and the trial and that outcome.
And, because there was
gonna be this trial,
I wanted him to get the
ultimate punishment.
I wanted him to get the death sentence.
And when the verdict was delivered,
for a couple of days, I was
actually very distraught.
But then I went to visit my daughter
at the cemetery and I always come back
from a visit with her,
maybe, feeling smarter,
because in her own way,
she communicates with me.
And I left the cemetery and I realized
no matter what happened to the killer,
every day going forward
I'm still gonna be visiting
my daughter at the cemetery.
Nothing changed, nothing changes.
And it put me in a place
where I was finally able to
put the killer out of my head.
He got the punishment he got.
He's going to one of the most
miserable places on earth
in the Florida Department of Corrections.
He will face ultimate
judgment there I'm sure.
But I'll still be visiting
my daughter at the cemetery.
And because of that, it was in that moment
where I was finally able to
put that killer out of my head.
He's no longer in my head.
I no longer think about him.
I no longer wonder what's
gonna happen to him.
I no longer
have any second or minute
of my time focused on him.
I'm no longer losing sleep over him.
And so while I was
disappointed in the verdict,
I'm actually now in a healthier place
than I've been for almost five years.
Well that's very good to
hear and important as well
because the only thing we can
control are our reactions.
Yeah.
I'm also just aware,
picking up what we were talking
a little bit about before
that we still, amazingly,
and I say that in the
true sense of the word,
have people who write horrific things
about these mass shootings,
who don't believe them.
Conspiracy theorists.
You'll be very familiar
with this terrain, sadly.
What do you think of Alex Jones?
I think Alex Jones
is the lowest form of
humanity that exists.
I wish him nothing but terrible outcomes
because of what he did to other
people and continues to do,
you know, in spite of these horrible,
financial legal judgments against him,
he hasn't stopped behaving badly.
He is a liar.
He is somebody who has
directed violence at others.
He has used his platform
not for good, but for evil.
And so in his remaining days on earth,
I hope he pays a horrible price
directed by the courts and
pursued by those families
that he spent all those years harassing.
And I am certain that when his time is up,
he will pay a final judgment as well.
He is as low a form of
human life as can exist.
You talk about use of platform.
I also noticed that when
the new owner of Twitter
the other day, Elon Musk,
posted a photo recently
of a bedside table cans of Diet Coke.
Also a gun, actually
transpired to be a toy gun
which I didn't realize at the time.
Sure.
You chose to post-
It actually doesn't matter
whether it was real or not
because the message he
was trying to deliver
is what matters.
Yeah.
I just meant I didn't know.
You know, but it was
a very striking image.
Sure.
You posted in response to that
talking about the fact that
your daughter was killed.
The everyday children are killed
because of irresponsible adults.
What do you feel about that
having also reflected on it?
It's so strange now
watching what Elon Musk
is turning himself into.
He is a business person
who I was mesmerized by
for so many years who I
thought did the coolest things.
And if he had a vision,
I automatically thought
if Elon Musk thinks he can pull
it off, I'll bet you he can.
I looked at him that way
until his pursuit of Twitter
and what he's turned it
into which is a cesspool
of indecency and the worst of humanity.
And that photo that he
posted is just an example.
He was, for whatever reason,
he felt important to post this image
of guns by the side of his bed.
I spend my life, every day, trying to talk
about responsible gun ownership
and locking weapons up.
Two of my dear friends, people
who I wish I didn't know,
but I do because of gun violence.
Mike and Kristin Song,
their son Ethan was killed
because of an unlocked weapon.
And so I don't care that
that wasn't a real weapon,
'cause he didn't say that in his message.
He implied he's keeping
these unlocked weapons
by the side of his bed.
And I find that dangerous.
And I find that encouraging to others
to do dumb, stupid, irresponsible things.
Why he's pursuing this
path in his life now?
Why he's behaving like the richest troll
on earth
instead of this successful business person
that he had previously been?
I can't make sense of,
but I hope he fails.
Well we'll see how that transpires
in terms of that platform and the owner,
ownership of that business
and perhaps also what changes
are or are not made.
Just finally,
what do you think Jaime would
make of what you're doing
and your fight and how
you're going about it?
You know, it's funny,
my wife and I have had numerous
conversations about that.
On one hand, she would
be completely embarrassed
by the attention.
'Cause while my daughter
was always out there
and performing, she was
still a shy little kid,
and she would be completely
embarrassed by the attention.
On the other hand, in my home,
my wife and my son are
very different than me.
They were never as into the news
and politics the way I was.
But Jaime was.
Jaime was the one who would
sit with me and watch.
And when I would get angry
at things that were happening
or uplifted by things that were
happening, she was with me.
She was participating.
And so Jaime, because of that,
and because of her toughness
because of her dislike of bullies,
because of her concern for others,
she would be, on the
one hand, embarrassed.
But on the other hand,
I know she would have
her hands on my back
saying 'go dad, do this'.
Let's save the next one.
She sounds like my kind of girl
getting very into it
her news, her politics
and trying to, you know,
stand up I suppose for what she believes.
Thank you so much for telling us about her
and also your work today.
Thank you.
I really appreciate the
time and the insights.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again, do
take care and goodbye.